da ich war einen grenzübergang
profile mit einer bürste grenzübergangs
profile an dem automaten bis zu 72
stunden zu fuß die bissstelle aber
trotzdem sich die frauen dort die 24
stunden kann man diese kennziffer ganzen
partys organisationen vor ort so platini
infrastruktur angeschlossen haben auch
von der grenzpolizei alles zeigen dass
man diesen trend geiz punkt haben dann
plötzlich eine familie zwar eine mutter
mit drei kindern die hamburg musste sich
angehörige und wusste nicht wie sie
dorthin kommen soll die trends
polizistin fragte mich ob ich helfen
könnte ich habe dann gesagt dann nehme
ich sie mit yoga wir nehmen sie mit ich
war mit einem freund zusammen da und
dann kam noch eine andere familie
ein rentnerpaar mit enkelin und dann
haben wir die gleich mit eingepackt und
somit unser politik dann von dieser
kritischen grenze bis nach
und sie sind ja auch in einem durch
gefahren wie ich im instagram post
gelesen habe was haben die menschen
ihnen denn vor ort gesagt was wird dort
jetzt wirklich am meisten benötigt was
ich auch ganz ganz viele bürger in
deutschland fragen wie kann man helfen
ich würde sagen die hilfsbereitschaft
war selten so groß wie gerade in diesem
land ja absolut hilfsbereitschaft ist
gigantisch nicht nur bei uns in
deutschland klappt das auch in polen so
in der form auch noch nie erlebt man
sieht in warschau keine kein bus keine
u-bahn berichten italienische flagge hat
auf den straßenschildern auf den
digitalen anzeigen in warschau auch auf
den polnischen autobahn wechseln die
verkehrshinweise dann mit help you frame
citizens auf englisch mit einer helpline
die dann eingeblendet wird also eine
unglaubliche solidarität überall unserer
englische flaggen und auch egal ob
regierung oder opposition ich meine das
hat putin geschafft in polen regierung
und opposition bei einer richtigen
politischen frage zusammenzuführen und
vielleicht selbst sogar wenige der
richtig mal dass und kriegen erfolg noch
einmal zusammen gepackt hat aber zu der
hilfe bitte das würde ich sagen keine
keine kleidung schicken an die polnische
grenze dort kommt sehr viel an ausholen
auch aus deutschland manchmal hat man
den eindruck da sein wem man was gutes
tun und wirft sachen weg die sowieso man
gar nicht mehr gebrauchen kann das kommt
dort an das ist nicht das was man
braucht auch bitte keine konserven in
deutschland kaufen und die dann mit
einem lkw nach polen bringen weil man
kann in polen sogar selbst im supermarkt
dinge einkaufen also man kann einfach
geld spendet das hilft am ehesten wenn
man helfen will ich empfehle dazu
entweder ganz konkret initiativen vor
ort auf der polnischen seite initiativen
in der ukraine oder eben die anerkannten
hilfsorganisationen und zwar von der
aktion deutschland hilft jeder der dort
registrierten mit mappus zertifiziert
und da lohnt sich an gespendet klaus wir
helfen ja auch bei bild mit ein herz für
kinder ein herz für kinder doch eine
groß angelegte aktion gestartet kann man
in all unseren medien sehen das finde
ich ganz ganz fantastisch ich würde es
ein bisschen an einer stelle vielleicht
anschaffen wollen das was paul team jagt
über die
altkleidersammlungen in
anführungszeichen sagt bewegt mich auch
also ich glaube dass die bilder über die
vielen menschen in not viele menschen in
deutschland extrem berühren und
gleichzeitig so eine art schlechtes
gewissen auslösen dass man nicht genau
weiß wie man helfen soll oder dass man
wüsste wie man helfen es soll aber es
ist so unbequem also hilft man lieber
nicht und dann schaut man mal im keller
ob man noch ein paar alte kleider hat
die man dann dahin schickt ich drücke es
einmalig wahrscheinlich der einzige der
das so sagt und da glaube ich müssen wir
noch zu uns finden also wenn eine
million menschen auf der flucht sind
oder vielleicht wie ich jetzt von der
uno gehört womöglich zehn millionen und
wir so nah dran sind dann ist es
natürlich mit einem alten winter pulli
nicht getan sondern dann ist die frage
haben wir gästezimmer haben wir super
wohnungen haben wir in villen platz für
menschen und ich finde dass es da
es gibt null zusammenhang und trotzdem
fühle ich den man kann schon sagen ein
russischer oligarch dem soll man sein
ganzes vermögen wegnehmen aber dann muss
man auch sagen wer jetzt hier in
deutschland ein großes vermögen hat den
immobilien der soll sie auch öffnen für
menschen in not und
ich habe ganz am anfang schon mal gesagt
dass ich angst habe vor den
lava bataillonen die dann beginnen
rumzulaufen die immer alles wissen wie
es gehen muss die immer alles
prophezeien und predigen dann muss man
auch selber dinge tun und das hält
unheimlich schwer ich habe diese
diskussion mit mir selber und meiner
familie auch gestern begonnen was was
tun wir denn und dann kommen da aus
dokumente naja aber dann wie ist das
denn dann sitzen alle beim frühstück
zusammen mit den fremden leuten und so
also ja das muss man ja einmal auch
analysieren weil wir könnten natürlich
noch viel mehr tun anders gesagt wenn
wir uns schon so schwertun waffen zu
schicken dann sollten wir uns wenigstens
um die menschen kümmern die darunter
leiden was die waffen der anderen antut
und dass das bewegt mich sehr und ich
bin weit davon entfernt zu sagen ihr
müsst ihr müsst ihr müsst ich sage nur
dass es auf euch wirken wenn ihr
menschen seid dann fällt euch sicher
irgendwas gutes ein was die abgabe des
winter pullis und der durch gelutscht
der schule schule übersteigt
darf daran vielleicht nur einen punkt
hinter fügen mir geht es mehr als ein
punkt auch richtig wir erleben jetzt
eine unglaublich große welle an
hilfsbereitschaft aber
ich habe heute zum beispiel eine einem
einfachen besuch bürger helfen bürger
bei mir in iserlohn die das übrigens
nicht nur jetzt tun sondern die ganze
zeit also über jahre hinweg menschen
helfen die auf der flucht sind und die
not sind und meine bitte ist an
diejenigen die heute helfen wollen aber
noch nicht wissen wie macht euch den
zettel liegt in den kalender für in
einem monat oder in zwei monaten drei
monaten wenn vielleicht man gar nicht
mehr so genau hinschauen wo es
vielleicht auch zu last wird weil es
wird auch mit herausforderung versehen
sein wenn so viele menschen nach polen
kommen nach deutschland kommen um dann
auch sagen jetzt sind wir dabei wenn
keine kamera man schaut